Now things are changing for your project, and for Andy's too.
[SOUND] I've got Andy on speed dial, number four.
Hey Andy can you come down to my desk for a second?
Great, thanks.
[SOUND] Now,
the project manager has changed the requirements in two different ways.
First of all, there's not one cat anymore.
Now there are two cats.
Second of all, the cat name should be above the cat image.
So how you implement that is completely up to you, but
I would recommend avoiding the most naive of solutions.
Don't just hardcode the cat name and the dom, or in the document.
Instead, store that in a JavaScript variable, and then update the document.
Hey Andy.
>> Hey, what's up?
>> So the project requirements have changed.
>> Okay.
Cat clicker duo.
>> Ooh, let me guess.
Two cats?
>> Two cats.
Can you do it?
>> I didn't plan for that, but I think I could probably figure it out.
>> Awesome.